have the best round of his his shooting
life right now reggie
but he can put a lot of pressure on him
let's see if he have a 28 round ranch
and put a lot of pressure on it i think
25 will win it 25 will win 25 we'll win
it i think we're going for 28. let's go
big fella money racks in the middle by
the way so he got the nervousness out
the way yeah he's more relaxed
he looks even more powerful than he does
his spot is coming up get hot
he's hot
douche zone ball i'm bad i just yell i'm
sorry
but remember he missed both of those due
balls his first time out and still
advanced first miss
on the money rack three out of four
make it four out of five oh yeah okay he
took a different path this time it's a
wrap get a ring
let's go it's a wrap
[Music]
reg i said 28 rich we need 28.00
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you called it you called it
oh it's a wrap okay
yeah that's a wrap now that is called
wanted to be known as the best big man
shooter ever look at that look at him oh
he's doing this
it's how you become known as the best
big man shooter ever
wow what a start good on the biggest
stage reg
hey he's got some hitters behind him
he got ice straight behind him
bernard oh yeah
[Music]
well he really got it going man on that
second round canard says slow it down
man
slow it down
carl anthony towns
kevin love won this event as a minnesota
timberwolf back in 2012 and the other
other big kiss me something
that's great carl anthony town
has won the mountain dew three-point
contest
that's great
okay big fella
big men rejoice
all over the world oh did you see that
interview he did with stephanie reddy
with the guys talking about look there's
no pressure i shot 40 on the season from
three i'm coming into this to win let's
do that
she said check my resume that's right
i want to show again his first
appearance in the three-point shooting
contest
carl anthony towns yes sir
wins
the mountain dew three-point contest man
that is something that is going to be a
memory
i have nothing to do with it i feel like
i don't know something you do
mark jason take it away mark